this week's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza also
bronx-born pizza in Portland Oregon gray
block in Los Angeles this week's episode
is also additionally brought to you by
the ridge the ridge is a wallet it's not
a condom the ridge is a wallet and it's
a front pocket wallet and you know a lot
of people you know you see somebody and
you're like oh what's wrong with them
are they you know were they in a fire or
did they somebody hit them with an axe
or something and nothing really happened
to them but they also have a big wallet
in their pants in the back pocket and
it's is it necessary I don't think it is
very old-fashioned the person even could
be a senior citizen but the new thing is
the ridge wallet and it's a front pocket
carry it minimizes which you carry so
you're not carrying it with extra bunch
of extra BS and I'm saying you're not
carrying an old treasure map printer you
know or um see you know some zydeco
sheet music you know wear a condom
you're not carrying all of that you're
just carrying your essentials Ridge
wallet comm slash Theo th EO for our
discount next weekend July 20th through
the 22nd I'll be at Charlie good nights
in Raleigh North Carolina August 4th
I'll be at Skyway Theatre in Minneapolis
Minnesota we just added a second show
August 16th and 18th Laugh Factory
Chicago Illinois
September 14th and 15th zany's in
Nashville October 18 18th through the
20th skyline comedy club in Appleton
Wisconsin and more dates they're all at
theof on comm slash tour thank you very
much for your support today's guest is a
positive light in the world and he's
also absolutely hilarious
he's a Sherpa our souls it is a mr.
Duncan Trussell
[Music]
yeah dude what if like your virtual
reality so say like yeah your audio like
your yeah like what if you like you what
if you could adjust the neighbor's house
volume like hack their house yeah I mean
that yeah that's like one of the really
insane looming problems with automation
is that theoretically everything will be
hackable especially if they get to the
point do they talk about some kind of
nano bot technology that you can inject
into your body that becomes a kind of
like accelerated white blood cell oh my
god so you could sort of look at your
phone and it's like oh [ __ ] you know
you've got a little bit of a cold virus
in there looming looming so it's in
you're just hanging on your elbow yeah
exactly right exactly and then
theoretically somebody could hack that
[ __ ] tell your white the nanobots to
start attacking your liver you know you
know I know yeah like what if somebody
so basically then it becomes like risk
like that game risk but you're able to
influence the like antibodies and the
negative and like the diseases and
things that are looming inside of
someone else's body that's right yeah
maybe let's [ __ ] heck uncle Larry I
do it skits really no one's talking
about this [ __ ] at all like we're
worried about stuff that's happening at
the second which of course is important
immigration everyone's pissed off about
Trump yeah or not pissed off about Trump
but everyone's ignoring the fact that
within the next 20 years we're probably
looking at 45% unemployment right full
automation oh dude I think about that
kind of stuff all the time like how many
like what happens when there are no jobs
except the only thing is uber and it's
everybody's an uber driver and they're
basically holding each other at gun but
those are automated now so there's
really no uber drivers because the cars
have been automated okay so you but I
know I think that we're talking with who
was the guy who made the song
cheeseburger
Jimmy Buffett yeah we're basically
talking to who I consider the Jimmy
Buffett of the future kind of like of
like in some ways could you like this
kind of peaceful character that takes
people on a beautiful adventure it's
like thinking about the future and stuff
and hearing you think about it it's like
it's in a comfortable way that people
have fun while they do it
yeah and so for some reason when I think
about you I think about Jimmy Buffett
and like um who was uh wrote and George
Orwell well thanks man I'll take that
I'll be that hybrid thank you so much oh
yeah that's a beautiful hybrid in
terrifying hybrid I like it
yeah like Bradbury maybe Bradbury is a
little more Orwellian Buffett like an
Orwellian Jimmy Buffett song that's
[ __ ] great now cheeseburger paradise
cheeseburger and some dystopian yeah
aaaggghhh filled city or everyone's
pretending to be happy or they get shot
yeah we're sitting here with Duncan
Trussell man and this is our first
conversation we were just talking about
that there's our first conversation and
yeah what does it look like when
everything is automated and how we like
at least some people are gonna be
educated enough to understand that
that's kind of what's going on yeah some
people are gonna feel threatened by
machinery and by automation like
different people are gonna react
differently well it seems to uh like
somebody's gonna go shoot up a [ __ ]
washer/dryer in their house you know I'm
saying out of fear yeah I mean that
there's going to be that but we're
looking already it's it's a problem like
a big problem which is that Oh like
humans in general many humans they have
jobs where they're supposed to work
eight hours a day but the amount of work
that they actually have they could get
done in two hours so they have to
pretend to work for the other six hours
so it's it's there's a I'm reading this
book called
[ __ ] jobs by David Graeber [ __ ] it's
great man but he just is you know
addressing the fact that we've gotten to
the point now where we really don't need
to work as much as we are
yeah but because the model of things is
that we
when we go to work we're selling our
time mm-hmm so that is I go to work I'm
selling you eight hours of time correct
which means I'm your slave for eight
hours essentially and so within that
eight hours if there's downtime the
employer feels like he's getting ripped
off right so she's like no you can't
just sit and look at the Internet even
though there's nothing to do yeah and so
you get punished for efficiency mm-hmm
if you can finish your job in two hours
you're gonna either lose six hours of
pay because you go home right or you're
gonna get chastised because you're
sitting around for the other six hours
so you have to start faking work and and
according to Graber this is like one of
the most psychologically brutal things
that can happen to a human to fake what
you could do efficiently yeah cuz it's
BDSM because it's a form of BDSM where
you have to sit and VDS it means to
suffer field I don't know it's like
brutal know about BDSM it's a bondage
domination I guess BDSM and
sadomasochism right it's like a it's
like great I'm glad you asked me that
cuz it's so funny I I love it and I
don't even know what the [ __ ] acronym
what it stands for oh I know like a
fussy a picture of a lady with like a
like a whip and like some you know sharp
stuff and some catsuit and like yeah you
see like some guy who's married but it's
just stopping at her house for an hour
yeah I know that that's medias that is
BDSM and I but I yeah but I don't know
what it means
bondage domination sadomasochism its
bondage and discipline discipline so
you're saying then so then having to
fake which you could be able to do just
to be able to keep your job in your pay
that's that that is brutal it's brutal
it's a person it's sick and if you don't
do it you're gonna get fired right so
you know that and though in and so he's
writing about the culture the way it
works is the employer knows that there's
not enough work so the the sickness of
it is you you have to you both kind of
have to lie to each other
mmm so not only are you having to do
this play act of pretending to work but
you're also like having to be dishonest
throughout the day you're having to and
because he says like what-what a define
a [ __ ] job
is that it really doesn't have any
impact at all in the world there's
really no need for it to exist but not
just that the employee knows that the
job is not doing anything as useless Wow
so you're you're many many people are
just stuck in this hell realm of just
essentially like pouring water out of
one cup into the other and then pouring
it back and then pouring it back right
and they're getting paid in a lot of
them get paid a lot of money yeah that's
the other thing he points out which is
really [ __ ] nuts which is the most
essential jobs the peat those people get
paid the least and the least essential
jobs those people get paid the most yeah
and then when you factor in all the
other um when you factor in the fact
that somebody got them the easiest one
cuz his [ __ ] dad was somebody like it
just yeah it just probably just creates
so much angst yeah exactly right yeah
but then we don't serve and the next
step is is is automation because it's
the next step is automation means that
the next step is that where we're at
yeah so the next step is gonna look like
I mean theoretically it's gonna look
like AI is going to get to the point
where it can start doing like accounting
and like law mm-hmm so not like trial
lawyers but most law involves like you
know creating a will or just thrilled
it's it's law's code laws code right so
AI is gonna get to the point where it
can create a will for you create a
prenup for you create a you know do all
the [ __ ] that you would have to go to a
human force and it's not just that it's
like gonna do the same thing for
accounting it's going to do the same
thing for pretty much anything that's
based on code right anything is based on
some of those books where there's not a
lot of you know where it doesn't have to
be argued exactly or it's kind of set in
stone and you already see that with like
LegalZoom you already see the the little
elements of that that are reaching out
to the people that are connecting us and
yeah we don't know what goes on next
thing you know you have a patent that's
right next thing you know you have a you
know you have an LLC set up exactly yeah
so it's like that so then so people
think that automation means oh yeah okay
so we're gonna
all the all the the the taxi industry is
gonna be completely automated and
fast-food chains well that'll be
completely automated and that's really
sad cuz fast-food workers they don't get
paid enough money for the work they do
they have these shitty jobs
yeah I'll tip them a lot of times I'll
throw over the lady ten bucks and we
should like we should I mean this is
this is a hell job in yeah that's the
other really crazy thing about our
society is we look down on those people
so there's a judgement if you work at
McDonald's right you're looked you're
shamed for that job and but your job is
[ __ ] hard and it sucks and if somebody
and there's always not doing [ __ ] right
[ __ ] Lawrence by the fries is never
[ __ ] do it [ __ ] he's trying to [ __ ]
right he's not doing any why Woody's
days barely getting paid he's burning
his skin you know the Roberta is doin
jerk hair he's picking up his extra
because she wants to get promoted yeah
so it's this sick vortex of like no get
the same drama of game of Game of
Thrones
it's taking place in McDonald's where
people are in this microcosm game of
fries game of fries but you see when
you're at the front desk do you know you
see like there's usually like a Latino
woman or like kind of like a middle-aged
black woman that's like or like a
redheaded kind of white lady that hasn't
been outside and long time and they're
like the leader there like devout and
they have like the little yeah you know
even a little tie up thing at the top of
the other dress or smock yeah and then
you see like somebody over by the window
biggest headset [ __ ] furious yes you
know yeah Bretton in people yeah
it's a hell realm and they're in and and
the the meat is sizzling and this all
the weird chemicals are blowing into
their face all day and and it's like a
making me hungry yeah it's delicious
food but it's a hell rum and so you're
saying that we so we have these jobs now
and people are living in these worlds
right right yeah so that's gonna become
automated so yeah so that's so what no
so what happens is the fast-food workers
rightfully want to get paid more because
they're like this is ridiculous that I'm
not getting paid a living wage
and so the people who are running the
franchises and running the corporations
know that it wants it I have to start
paying my workers $20 an hour for 25 or
23 or $17 an hour at some point the
amount I have to pay them becomes more
expensive than the amount I would have
to pay to implement robots automation
and so at that point it becomes
pointless to use a human anymore
right so that that's what called a
market pressure right so once it crosses
past whatever that boundary is that
pushes us closer to full automation so
those people now don't have jobs and the
uber drivers don't have jobs but not
just the uber drivers the truck drivers
don't have jobs anymore right so in that
central I don't take away my truckers
when I'm gone don't so that's gone and
now when the truck drivers don't have
jobs guess what goes next the [ __ ]
truck stops and all the little towns and
that are built on the economy of truck
stopping on the highway yes stop and get
a smoothie stop and get a jerk-off
whatever yeah well I would come over
there I could get some gas and come over
here I understood that is exactly right
although all of those one of the trucker
prostitutes called
a lot lizards they called a lot lizards
yeah all the lot lizards they have to go
slithering where there's going to be a
[ __ ] it's gonna be like a refugee
crisis lot was it just slither into
Vegas state okay yeah just this heating
up in Sedona slithering through the
rocks and just rising up over Vegas just
and that's it [ __ ] yeah name what are
we gonna do with them you know what are
we gonna do with all the lot lizards
this is the future these are the
problems of the future okay now I ask
you this now does there come a point
though where it for an owner of a
business where it has the ability to go
with the market pressure we have the
option for automation right to go there
and you don't want to on a financial
sheet that makes total sense yeah but
where then it becomes and like where
does emotion come into that where like
an owner is like you know what no I'm
not going to do that because I keep my
business open now because and then this
becomes a thing of pride yeah like
almost
Americanism yes where I keep my business
open because I want to employ people
that are good hard-working people that
want good that that deserve to have
money well here's where we run into a
very interesting ethical problem which
is right now because of the Industrial
Revolution there's a very sick idea
which is that if a person isn't
constantly working then they're lazy so
it's like if you're not always you
should always be working if you're not
working you should be looking for a
[ __ ] job right and and because like
we've defined ourselves based on the
Industrial Revolution we've defined
ourselves as beings that should always
be working and not only that but we've
we're defining ourselves by Factory
ethics so especially our parents yeah
especially our parents but but even
today you know what you know like what
is it I don't want no scrub scrub is go
and get a little love from me sitting in
the passenger side of his best friend's
right so if you know if you're not in
debt to the banks to pay for a [ __ ]
car an explorer then you're not a
[ __ ] you're not gonna make you can't
even reproduce yeah so there's this
entire industrial revolution and
doctrine ation that has taken over
people's brains this is all from graters
book I'm all fired no I love it and this
is David Graeber book yeah I said and we
want the link of that below [ __ ]
jobs it's great well it sounds
fascinating man and I you know what I
love man it's so neat to have you in
here because I know that you're such
like um like you're such a neat thinker
you know like many people it sounds like
for anyway everything I've heard is that
people like you just got blessed with
like a really unique brain and you're
kind of like a sharecropper of your own
brain you know like you like to take
care of your brain and like mine the
fields and you get out there and kind of
you know you're not just [ __ ] letting
all the weeds grow in your brain you
know you're kind of like okay I'm a ten
to my brain you know I'm gonna see
what's going on we'll see what's growing
here and see what's I mean anyway I'm
just kinda I'm not judging you I just
I'm just kind of weirdly describing you
and I'm sorry about that but do you mean
like when you say attending to the weeds
and your bird you tender that your brain
I think I've just started to become more
aware
and it's honestly been because of you
know pretty much probably because of
getting into podcasting right and
there's people in these worlds that are
kind of like pioneers of that sort of
thing and then I start listening to
podcast yeah and I start like you know
um the Shane Moss document like I start
thinking about these things that are
going on and like people are like micro
dosing how people are starting to think
about how who how how we think and feel
are starting to become a lot more of a
value outside of like text books right
and sort of examining that yeah that's
kind of where I'm at I'm I'm more in the
feeling space I think like I'm kind of
obsessed with feelings ah yeah but I
love the fact that there are guys like
you out there where do your feelings
show up my feelings show up a lot
honestly in just even moments like this
and your but where in your body do they
show up right up in here kind of right
yeah honestly get my tear ducts a little
bit my feelings are so like there's not
very much between like whatever moment
is going on and like whatever like my
feelings are like right there like I can
feel them like in here I'm a face some I
can feel them in my throat alive yeah
that's great man that's a there's a an
idea that I've been taught which is that
you know most people are up in their
heads and that's where they live and
they're pretty and it's a pretty
emotionless space like if you get in
fact some people try to escape from
their feelings into their thoughts
because that they would rather but
purely intellectualize the world right
then to experience even like a second of
actual emotion because emotion is
especially if you've been putting off
feeling it's quite painful
yeah and humans are we like to avoid
pain so yeah you basically many people
are like Howard was that guy's name
Howard Hughes wasn't he recluse he lived
up in a mansion or something yeah he'd
be in the dark all day for yes at a time
yeah so that's what many people have
retreated into their minds into a little
corner of their minds and they just live
up there looking at their thoughts and
desperately try not to feel yeah and so
and not
knowing they can some of them right not
even know and when when it starts where
the feelings start hmm they're like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that and then tears
start coming no yeah no no no it's like
a damn it's like when you see in those
videos on the news where this dam is
about to [ __ ] break yeah and it's
good if it breaks then they haven't it's
what we call in the West a nervous
breakdown right is when all that dammed
up emotion comes flooding out of their
heart yeah into their minds and then
they start jabbering and freaking out
and like and it's all because they've
been pushing down all this emotion so
I've been taught that that it's a it's a
good thing to if you can begin to sort
of move into your heart yeah more than
then in your mind or at least balance
the two out a little bit yeah yeah I
start to feel even more as I get and
like I got into like sobriety like I got
sober a couple years ago so that's when
that kind of stuff all happened for me a
little bit like yeah but I never thought
there was any I I was all thoughts I
never knew I never knew I knew I had
feelings but I had to create all my
feelings with my brain like if I loved
you you know I had to like her it was
almost like okay I decided that I love
them you know and to me that's what all
love wasn't like a man it's been and and
I didn't realize like just what a cage
that and I didn't know I had no idea
right that there was this other like
feet there was these feelings this vow
this thing that it was almost like a
like under the plates of the earth
sometimes if you see like the magma and
you know I just I didn't know yeah and
so even just two years ago almost July
17th will be two years where I just kind
of got into 12-step program but anyway
some of that helped me start to change a
perspective switch yeah and I'm like oh
my god this is what people have been
doing this this whole time and I didn't
know that this I didn't know that
my feelings don't happen in my brain
isn't that wild probably I kid you not
dude there's been nothing more that's
been earth shattering almost in a lot of
ways rebirth yeah a hundred percent man
reincarnation you could almost say
there's a story of I don't know it's
some Taoist master they asked
they would they would say how old are
you he was like 80 but he'd be like four
and because he didn't consider the years
before is awakening meaning actually
life yeah that was like a robotic
existence and so it's a there's many
ways people talk about it
one of it one of them is it's like
you're living this little shack mm-hmm
and you think the shack is your is all
your home mm-hmm I mean think how
incredible would be if you were living
in a shack and then all of a sudden you
realize like I think there's a [ __ ]
trapdoor here and you open it up and it
leads into like this glorious beautiful
maybe a little dusty
mansion a temple yeah and suddenly you
leave this tiny little space into this
spaciousness of self and that is for
many people like one of the greatest
things that can happen to it Wow it can
happen
wow that's amazing to think of it like
that yeah it makes me just start to
really feel like for the first time in
life I could really kind of feel you
know like nothing became Sattar to me
then like like like when a kid doesn't
have like when a kid doesn't feel like
somebody loves them or cares about him
like nothing like makes me sadder than
that now
for some reason and I never had that
feeling I never had it's just it's
interesting man it's just like yeah I
feel like I'm out here like kind of
spelunking in my own feelings a little
bit yeah and it's fun and it's a scary
sometimes and I noticed like a lot of
times I'll try and step back into my own
so in my old ways and so I have to make
it a practice to not do that yes it is a
practice hmm
it's yes you do have to train train
yourself it straight it's it's you can I
mean its cultivation and Buddhism it's
something you actually and I think that
that's a it's an interesting thing in
the West where we just think that you
you know love is like a baseline thing
that is equivalent for everyone right
yeah it's like love is like well the
ways
the way waters wet love is love love but
really the ideas like these are things
you can actually not only Colt you can
cultivate and explore and go very deep
into and dial-in and people have been
spending thousands of years yeah
learning about that how to do that in
exploring what what that is but here we
don't really think about it that much
but I feel like in this I feel like guys
and I mean even guys like you and other
you know other podcasters other thinkers
other guys that are really starting to
get voices in the world I feel like are
kind of pioneers of this awaking of this
awakening and making this awakening more
popular and more okay for just kind of
regular people who were thought that a
this wasn't accessible in their life
yeah
or be they would seem like a weirdo
right you know or fear or even like I'll
have people email me a podcast like do
you said something the other day and not
like I'm any kind of like go girl just
how to share what I'm feeling if I can
and like it and I didn't and it made me
see something a little different you
know yeah well you're right this is the
the way that I am what makes me excited
about it is um because like if you know
by the time I don't know you're yet
you're a young guy 1:38 well I'm 44 are
you really yeah so I'm old not old oh
but old so like but by the time you get
to be around my age maybe not your age
so much I don't know it's different for
everybody but you've sort of been like
serving yourself mm-hmm your whole life
if you're me if you're a selfish prick
you know what I mean it's selfish its
selfish there's a culture of self
selfishness in the world and in or
what's called self-cherishing so mmm
that's interesting
yeah self chair that's very American it
seems like yeah it is it really is it
and you sort of you end up and you think
it's it's an okay way to be so you're
always interested a self-cherishing
person you get into any environment and
you want to make adjust adjustments to
fit what you
think it's going to make you feel better
in that moment so for many people this
means disregarding what other people
want in that environment and making it
your music your thing your color wall
your whatever it is right
self-cherishing oh yeah I could see
myself being like that a lot yeah and
it's a survival so it's also a survival
element for a lot of people when they
grow up like if you you know as a kid
the world revolves around you you don't
know that there's any outside input at
all like I mean you know this outside
input but you don't know that like when
you're eight years old you don't really
know that your buddy Tommy has feelings
as much I mean it's all your world yeah
you know it's so like first player
shooter yeah that's it yes and
especially if you're being taught to
live up in your head so if you if you
manage to turn your emotions off and you
live in your head it becomes very easy
to do that to other people because
you've heard you've dehumanized them
you've reduced them to a kind of pixel
floating around you and you haven't even
like thought for a moment that that
person had a mom and a dad wakes up and
feels something and is maybe super sad
or super stressed out or super freaked
out you can't think about that because
the cognitive dissonance that starts
happening when you begin to realize that
we're all not individual units but
completely interrelated becomes so
overwhelming that your ability to
navigate as a selfish person begins to
fall apart and that's scary and that's
almost that's shocking it's like telling
you you've been driving your car your
whole life and then now everybody's it
doesn't matter where you're going we're
all weight matters where we're all going
yeah like what the [ __ ] well uh not
going to do not even that but but but we
are fundamentally connected yes so so
for example you know when you think in
terms of what makes a person a person
and that question is complex but you
could say well it's my awareness I have
this sense of a self I'm aware Here I am
I have a self I have a body
but then not only that I'm aware of you
and I'm aware of this room so if I
remove all of these things then what am
i I kind of cease to be my existence is
predicated by relationships by my in
fact I people think they live in their
their bodies but maybe it would be more
apt to say we live in our connections to
other people hmm
we're completely interrelated you know
and so if that's the case and we've been
fixated on ourselves instead of our the
quality of being connected to others
then there's a pretty good possibility
we're miserable
hmm because we haven't we're essentially
a muscle cramp you know we're like a
sentient muscle cramp that's become so
embroiled in trying to make sure it's
okay that it is disconnected from the
circulatory system
you're like a barnacle almost yeah I got
a fear out of something we got so last
and that's where we just have been like
just uh calcifying and the whole time
this oceans going on right on our back
and we don't even [ __ ] know that's it
that all we're supposed to do is just
let go and realize we're part of
something so much bigger yeah that's it
that's it do you think that so at this
time we're becoming so automated though
at the same time does it seem [ __ ]
bizarre that I feel like people are
getting so obsessed with what other
purpose is there for us as you're like
you know are starting to do those does
that really fit together it doesn't seem
like it does well see this is the great
reckoning because you know if
I think Carl is Carl Jung that said that
the shadow but the shadow the the the
Kim the the collective shadow that the
repressed aspects of a society get
reflected in their leader right so if
there's a lot of repression happening in
a society then you might get some kind
of leader that is like a reflection of
that repression and so if we're living
in a world where we've been taught where
but as a matter of survival you got to
be up in your [ __ ] head
yeah if you're waking up at 5 a.m.
you're maybe driving an hour and a half
through traffic to get to a job that you
know doesn't really help anybody and and
and where you have to fake work and and
and maybe you even have to fake
happiness like I might be in a public
job so you have to fake happiness and
then you maybe will have and at ten
thirty minutes to yourself every day not
including your sleep cycle mm-hmm so
collectively that means that we've all
probably been retreating up into our
minds because to try to be in your heart
in that situation must be incredibly
painful right yes because then you would
really be feeling it in you it you would
be giving into that party that's like
always like I don't know if I'm having a
lot of effect on the world or if I'm
really yeah creating a you know farming
myself the best that's it and so the
reckoning might be then collectively if
enough people have been repressing
themselves emotionally and living in
their heads as an order of survival
because they've been put in an
existential untenable situation that is
absurd essentially then the reckoning
would be when suddenly there becomes no
more thing to do like that and now
everyone has to go back and has to feel
again but collectively Wow
so now we have an entire the entire
society has a kind of nervous breakdown
the entire society has a kind of
meltdown and what does that look like
what does that look like when suddenly
humanity is forced to come to terms with
something that seems really obvious yeah
which is that a per
Sion's life is not meant for work right
Wow
and then and that feels like exactly
manna I I don't know if I could deny
that that feels like exactly where we
are headed
yes it's tech technology is forcing this
it seems like and you know one of the
great was writing about how like slave
owners used to used to say you got to
keep these [ __ ] busy because if
you don't they're gonna run they're
gonna run you know they were demented
monstrous people who are like fully
aware of the human psyche and they knew
that if they're these human beings that
they had captured were given any amount
of free time how they would split so
yeah people so if I am wanting to
control a society and I'm wanting to
harvest their energy then the last thing
I want is for them a free time right wow
I wonder if at some point for some slave
owners and throughout time you know and
I'm not just talking about in America
but you know every continent that that
they were like [ __ ] do we have to eat it
was almost painful to know I think there
were like some nice slave owners in a
weird way like it was it I have to keep
them busy because if I don't they'll
start to think yeah well yeah yeah I
mean they're there so to communicate
they'll start to you know yeah because
you it's not like that you don't hear
the strongest there's not that story
that the strongest slave changed at all
it's the thinker slave it's the
Frederick duck you know it's the leaders
it's the it's yes the thinkers yeah it's
the thinkers and in the feelers and and
and that in that connectors right you
know cuz that's the the reality it's not
like slave adaptil you know the
strongest let you don't say like even
though they'd be a great superhero guy
who came in and just changed it all you
know you mean like a pterodactyl slave I
mean I'm not talking about a sleeve that
[ __ ] a bird but I'm talking about like
a slave that you know I've just picked a
bad name up I mean like an Iron Man
give him free time they'll start the
[ __ ] Birds I mean like an Iron Man
type of person I know it would be a
great I mean this is the tragedy of the
of it all is that you know they were so
controlled and so terrified and so
intentionally disempowered and broken
that they they you know that they
couldn't unify but that's the difference
between us us and them and that's kind
of the big like the reality the big I
guess thing you're not supposed to say
or the thing that's really quite obvious
which is that there is way more of us
than there are of them and by us I mean
people who are you know human beings
right you don't feel like being
exploited or objectified there's just so
much more of us yeah we seem so it
almost starts to seem Sol upset it
starts to seem like yeah why have we
been the slaves for so long right and
that's if you were running a plantation
and you heard that conversation you
would want to figure out a way to make
that conversation not happen right so
what would you do so maybe you would
like okay [ __ ] you know somehow these
slaves have gotten access to technology
they're starting figure to figure some
stuff out ra ra all right all right well
let's make the slaves imagine they do
have a little bit of power and then
have some autonomy it's like now we
don't have slavery we have job so right
now it's like okay so you go to work you
got a job Congrats unemployment
[Applause]
meanwhile it's like what does that
really mean it means it like a [ __ ] ton
of people are getting splattered with
like grease that's burning them a lot of
people are doing things lord of the
fries man they're at the [ __ ] TSA oh
yeah TSA is the worst day yeah
can you imagine the misery of that job
which is you know because when you come
in they they they want people to be
compassionate yeah people are doing
security theater so they have secured it
yeah that's what it's called security
theater security fear it's
so ridiculous yeah yeah it is and they
put up signs which is like just you know
80% of these people are veterans yeah
and so the idea is like because human
humans are having a natural reaction to
strangers rifling through their [ __ ]
yeah and and and and their cons to the
TSA workers but it's like if you really
think about it imagine every day you
have to drive to LAX just think of that
every day you have to drive to [ __ ]
LA and don't go anywhere and don't go
anywhere that you're in the worst part
of LAX Oh Whitten you and then and you
have to sit there looking like that the
[ __ ] look probably looking at that
people's dicks all day through that
machine so like you're seeing these like
you're just looking at [ __ ] like just
like American a naked Americans and you
know these people aren't bringing bombs
and these people aren't doing [ __ ]
that's an 80 year old woman in a [ __ ]
wheelchair do I really need to grab her
[ __ ] right now to see if there's a
[ __ ] stick of dynamite up there I
mean kinda that's the fun as far yeah
but yeah do I need to write like you
yeah like like but yeah do any of these
TSA workers there's some that are pretty
probably a weight that really we're not
doing anything yeah and you they know
and then they add to that that they're
experiencing this river of sentient
humans who are glaring at them all day
yeah I'm the worst yeah yeah yeah and
and so so this is like a this is a
hellscape but but because of the TSA we
created a [ __ ] ton of jobs right right
and so then that makes the numbers look
good yeah yeah and it makes us feel like
we're doing something good that's right
and so it's like okay let's invent some
other [ __ ] [ __ ] thing for people
to do that we all know really doesn't
need to happen and then another thing
and another thing and all of this is
just this basically if you I mean like
imagine how dangerous it would be if you
are a tiger herder now this has never
happened of course but
you had to herd Tigers mm-hmm
you would that that that's not a racial
slur II don't nobody thinking it is what
do you mean it's not this chicken it's
no okay imagine he had to herd Tigers go
on I'm in this he would be [ __ ] scared
shitless right because you'd be like man
these Tigers if they figure out their
Tigers mm-hmm then there's no way
they're gonna let us hurt them anymore
because they're way bigger than us
they're fast they're dangerous but then
think how much more dangerous humans are
than Tigers
we are devious technological creatures
that are learning how to go to the
fundamental elements of the universe and
reconfigure we can reconfigure atoms we
know how to we are such amazing beings
so much potential and we're being herded
and the way we're being herded is by
being told that time is money
yeah right and so we're being herded by
and pulsed or being pulsed so it's like
if you look over a city you see this
like which is red light green light red
light green light whoop it's a
circulatory system a pulsing circulatory
system of sentient advanced beings in
metal shells who all think that they're
doing something unique but if you looked
at it from the sky it's no different
than looking at ants carrying bread from
a picnic it's just a it's a hive right
and the hive is being pulsed and the
thing that's pulsing that hive well I'm
not really sure exactly what that is
bright that's where and that's a big
question kind of because that's the same
question I get to with like I mean it's
not the same of the same tributary that
I arrived there from but it's the same
place River that I get to when I get to
the the question of who's doing it right
and why who's doing it or we just have
we just gotten into this and we just
gotten into this calcified [ __ ]
whirlpool where we're just doing it to
ourselves you know I don't think I think
I think it's like
I imagine if you want--if like in some
dark universe if you wanted to run a
laboratory where you had access to you
know a bunch of babies and you could
just raise them you could probably make
the babies believe that every morning
when you wake up you walk six times
clockwise and every 45 minutes you walk
counterclockwise you have neighbors
radiance yeah right as soon as they can
walk but then like the babies if you
especially if you like started
electrocuting them if they didn't do
this ritual so maybe these kids are all
wearing some kind of shock collars or
something so they have to do this ritual
every 45 minutes or they get shocked
probably by the time they're sixteen you
could take the shock collar off and
they're gonna spend the rest of their
life in the laboratory yeah doing this
[ __ ] thing so I think probably what
happened is maybe during the Industrial
Revolution a bunch of wait we were just
taught something that was a was just a
complete and absolute lie which is that
you can sell time yeah
and and that's nothing to be more
valuable than them more of a [ __ ]
yeah it's not true you can't sell time
in fact I don't even know what time is
but and it's probably such a critical
moment too because there's so much going
on that yeah the thing and I think it's
weird cuz there's people that want us to
work so much some people want life to be
about work and they want life to be
about money yeah and that's very
alarming to me yeah like I start to
really believe that there's gonna be a
thing where greed is not [ __ ]
attractive anymore right like I want to
do well for myself like I want to
succeed yeah I want to have you know
there's some things I want to have all
my children to have like you know be
able to clean their teeth at night and
you know and like I feel like a
comfortable blanket on their scanning
like things like that you know yeah but
I don't know if it's money I feel like
that drives me and if it really gets to
be like that that kind of scares me a
little
I wonder if that school of thought is
gonna start to take over that greed is
not it's not [ __ ] cool anymore when
we know so much that other like beings
are struggling yeah man it's not cool
it's not it well in it in its
painful I mean that's the you know when
people have a [ __ ] ton of money yeah
many of them are philanthropists because
they figured out that like what is the
best feeling right giving it away yeah
and so they're they're they're
philanthropists and in there and they're
giving it away but generally like the
experience of selfishness is
self-cherishing is incredibly painful
and people don't realize that so yeah
trying to load up on money is act is is
is a an attempt to reduce their levels
of suffering right yes and that's a debt
that that I think that's it that makes
sense to me like if it's like trying to
put but the problem yeah it's trying to
put out a fire with more fire yeah and
it just doesn't work it's just it's just
that it's like oh I'm thirsty god I'm so
[ __ ] thirsty let me eat sand yeah
that'll help me not be thirsty anymore
and and so I think that's kind of the
problem is well the thing you're talking
about I hope what happens is that people
start realizing that because we're all
connected I tend to feel better if I'm
doing stuff for other people yeah more
than if I'm doing [ __ ] for myself and
that's what 12-step programs are that's
what all that is all that is stuff is
about usually is getting back to
realizing that the way you get out of
whatever is hurting you a lot of times
is by helping somebody else you're not
thinking about yourself yes that's the
it's it's like if you want the antidote
to whatever ails you just start helping
someone yeah and you it's like so easy
to do it's it's you know right away like
you can do a scan right away and and
think who needs help in my life I'm not
talking about some kind of like distant
sending money off to charity or anything
like that that's great do it if you feel
like it I'm talking about
well this teacher jack Kornfield he live
out of my podcast he says tend to the
part of the garden you can touch so just
think like who who needs help who needs
a hug you need somebody to take one
Alana - do you notice that's been
drinking a lot and and instead of joking
about it with your friends and make it
one of them which is okay to do a couple
times more but also hookah probably is
hurting and maybe could use some you
know and all they need is just somebody
to care yeah you know it's crazy the
scary something in the weird and in the
weirdest way I was just thinking about
this a minute ago is looking at Jen I
was like how scary would it be if I
thought that you loved me you know like
not in like a homoerotic type of way but
how scary would it be if we approached
people and the first thought we had was
right that this person loves me yeah
yeah like really like if you like it
would ever change the whole just changed
it would take me so much out of like
whatever fear that I lived in right but
it's for some reason that's not the way
that we are built to do it here you know
what a bird dog is don't you it's when
you a girl no it's not a sex move a bird
dog is actually a pair of beautiful
shorts and these are shorts that are
also swim trunks and they're also
underwear and they're basically
everything it's the one stop shop for
the top of your legs and butt and crotch
and bird dogs have beautiful you know
beautiful different colors assortments
you can wear them different places
people love them people like oh what as
are those you know from outer space or
from Egypt and you're like nah these are
bird dogs you can workout in them you
can do whatever you want a lot of people
you know wearing underwear and shorts is
insane really it's almost something you
would only see somebody doing a mental
health center and so now you don't have
to do that anymore you can be natural
150 percent natural even with bird dogs
and they got them panties built-in than
male panties so go to bird dogs calm and
enter code Vaughn vo in and get a they
throwing that free dad hat so if you're
a dad or even if you want to be you just
want to let the ladies at the pool know
that you could spray okay you know and
you get that potential for father ship
then go to bird dogs calm and use code
Vaughn get that free hat get them bird
dogs look beautiful at the pool or
anywhere you want get that hitter and
one of the ironies about like bringing
like the
about bringing slavery whenever they
brought slaves to America or probably
anywhere really I better specifically
Americas we took these people that
probably didn't have that probably had a
lot of like neat practices and they were
probably down earth practices and like
yeah you know a caring environment and
then we bring them into this place you
know yeah but that thing you're talking
about the love yeah this is that this
can be cultivated so sometimes you'll
run into people who've cultivated that
and they do love you running around them
but it's an in it so it's sort of like
the the idea is it like on one level we
have the ego identity mm-hmm right which
is just all our stuff and the games that
we play and all this stuff like your
identity as a podcaster your identity as
a comedian everything that you do and
then the other level is like this soul
level and that's love that's your heart
that's this universal eternal identity
that that is so beautiful
yeah so there's a thing when people are
dying it's called Fae light if you ever
heard this before
Fae light I know I'm gonna from the
south so I'll probably know a couple of
women name there may be light I think
I'd a bus driver networks don't dress
that button she stole Darryl's [ __ ]
dog they light stole Daryl dog and burn
his [ __ ] with a cigar and dropped it
off with a bow on its head that's a lie
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] every time he sheds
he out there we had a woman named dot
wall was I'm gonna bust out that wall
dude seven letters baby as was he used
to say that was their motto after she
say her name seven letters baby beat
that that's what she would say and we
had a man named Milford King who wore no
shirt two days he were no shirt and
[ __ ] droves a big guy no fur that's
cool he was wild I saw him [ __ ] throw
a senior citizen who would ditch fire in
the man died and that was [ __ ] pretty
absorbed what we through a senior
citizen and they dryer they were
fighting next to a ditch fire yeah dude
if you ever ate my fries bruh game of
5-inch fire that's like
when you're a kid and they show you the
pictures of the dinosaurs on top of each
other like you know they show like the
brontosaurus with a dinosaur just
pulling back at Hitler that's just a
primordial oh yeah [ __ ] Milford fine
[ __ ] fighting with a stink of a ditch
fire blowing against him as he finally
grabs some poor elderly as he didn't
just is like overcome so just throws him
in a ditch fire Garry Pulido and Garry
Pulido camera came out that fire on fire
still swinging at Milford he was a hot
he was maybe 200 percent of town dude
was the fire and the Italians gonna
swing and [ __ ] burn at the same time
and they were fighting by the ditch
because they both have their shirts off
and it was cold out so you want to be
close to it you want to stay warm while
you fight that was their whole idea was
the ditched is filled with my burning
senior citizens heat I don't know if
I'll body fire no victims just leaves
dude and probably some recyclables
but this before they had recycles isn't
back when you could [ __ ] burn
whatever you and let just let the moon
[ __ ] take a hit off your [ __ ]
noxious gas [ __ ] lift up yeah let a
[ __ ] bird get it off this [ __ ]
melting uh yeah off this burnin milk
rocket just throw the jugs in there or
whatever and you would smell it you just
just smell it on the wind [ __ ] yeah
those trash like me erected the original
viagra dude yeah it still happens smell
of fossil fuels burn in the distance
dude I'll come right now bro but sorry I
don't mean to digress and all that but I
know uh so what we were what were we
talking because I was in our
conversation sometimes it is to off a
light oh yeah this a light yeah we're
talking about that feeling when
someone's dying what's really
interesting if you get around a dying
person is is you'll notice that like the
room kind of lights up hmm and that's
called fate Fae light that's the name of
it and if you get around a newborn or if
you get around a pregnant person you
know you know pregnant women they have
this glove yeah so the idea is like what
you're seeing there is like a soul that
has yet to be covered up by the lantern
of the but by that by personality right
and so and so that's why in the you know
when people in the in when you see the
paintings of the disciples
of Christ they have halos but really
what they were saying is like they there
was like this emanation coming out of
them because their identity had been
obliterated by being in the presence of
this enlightened being Wow right so that
thing you're talking about you know
loving someone
well loving someone's identity you could
probably do it and you can do it you can
love someone's identity but that's like
loving kind of like the drops at the
very top of a fountain but if you get to
the Fountainhead which is the thing it's
all that stuff's emanating from yeah way
down there that's love it's beautiful in
its beauty and you can train yourself to
start seeing that in people Wow so when
you're conversing with them you're
having one conversation which is like
the the identity [ __ ] mm-hmm but if you
can do it theoretically then you you it
you could actually begin talking to the
thing that's on that's behind that fog
of self and they'll feel it you know you
could feel that you know there's some
moments man oh man I'm so thankful you
came here today it is so having me dude
it's so cool and I'm not trying to end
the conversation anything I just wanted
to let you know that I was thinking
about that just now but dude it when you
said that your personality is like this
rapping that's around you no rest you
have never because I do feel like yeah I
feel like there's all this this stuff
and these things that are going on but
then I feel like there's this like it's
almost like you ever see the clay on a
spinning wheel in the clay just sitting
there and like this wet kind of like it
looks like a upside-down pot kind of you
know I feel like that is always kind of
going inside of me yeah and then there's
this other there's other [ __ ] outside of
it there's ornaments there's wrapping
there's it's like this Cadbury egg and
they put this colorful [ __ ] film
around it and that's the personality
yeah but then I do slowly broke no joke
and it may be something happens with age
you start to feel that there's that I'm
something outside of whatever this other
stuff is outside of outside of where I
am even at this moment yeah that I'm
something that
is that wants to feel I think for me
right now my life it's that wants to
feel kind of accepted you know
yeah and that wants to accept others so
that are just something around there I
just feel something below the
personality I'd never heard of of the
personalities being like a rapping or
it's it's compared to a lantern that's
got like a blanche devereaux kinda thing
- darn it what suppose Deborah she put
those things over the lantern in that
Tennessee Williams or whatever she put
the you know the color thing around the
light just a light but then there was
this color wrap that's it yeah that's it
and for some people that it's not it's
it's not such it's not so pretty well
it's all of this like you know it's it's
sort of oily and dirty and dark and so
these you know and that's called karma
so your your karma is sort of like
gotten and not just from this
incarnation but from infinite
incarnations his covering this up
and so what those are the people who are
looking through that sort of when she'll
just covered in and [ __ ] splattered
bugs and and those are the people who
wherever they are they're unhappy yeah
and and they always will report in that
the world is this miserable place right
and what they don't realize is that it's
oh no no you you've got a bunch of [ __ ]
on your windshield yeah and the practice
whatever a practice you choose that
starts clearing the windshield away the
smudge and then all of a sudden this is
where it gets really [ __ ] cool is
like yeah I've noticed person I used to
be there's if some things that used to
bother the [ __ ] out of me and by the way
man I just got to say this because I'm
starting to realize sometimes I've come
across like I'm some kind of [ __ ]
like I've done the work and I am no I
don't think you just sound like a guy
who's on the on the like he chose to
walk into the woods I'm a [ __ ] I just
want to say that okay man I do kunti
things and kunti [ __ ] happens all the
time and I get real country sometimes so
that being that being said one of the
things I that really used to bug me
was crying babies on an airplane oh yeah
right
oh my god I would get so [ __ ] mad
another thing that would bother me as if
I was like putting my arm on the armrest
and then someone was using the armrest
right and and and all these [ __ ]
external things are kind of outside your
control what you notice is all these
things that used to stick out that
bothered you they start fading back you
know the background they stop bothering
you and then you start realizing oh [ __ ]
it wasn't the thing it was in me and I
was projecting that onto the screen of
the crying baby in the [ __ ] arm and
the traffic and then once you deal with
the thing down in there then the stuff
out here it still sucks I'm not saying
when a baby cries on the right lane I'm
not like I feel so great but it doesn't
[ __ ] go directly to some point of me
that's ready for hatred right it's not a
knife in your heart right you're not
fantasizing about well [ __ ] maybe maybe
the [ __ ] window and the plane will
break out and that [ __ ] baby will get
sucked into the things that go but I
think a lot of times you start to think
like oh maybe the baby is not feeling
well and I just used to be like who the
[ __ ] is taking a baby in a rocket you
know there's a baby in a rocket
it's self-cherishing yeah we become
these little [ __ ] princes right and
then you realize [ __ ] the crying child
is not really on the plane it's in my
brain right there's a [ __ ] legion of
screaming and everything in my brain and
if it weren't that baby would be
something else it would be something
else it would be something else exactly
okay I'll be damned if I'm gonna run out
of things to piss me off so that I have
to actually maybe enjoy my [ __ ]
moment yes right that's it
and and so that's a relief cause if I
enjoy my moment then what is that and
that for some reason we feel like that
it gives it makes us weak somehow yeah
exactly that's right man that's it
that's where it gets really perverse is
you start realizing like there is a yeah
f ing oh my momma what does it mean if I
enjoy my moment right now
you can't you can't do that no what does
it mean that's what I'm trying to them
like what does it mean if you're
enjoying your moment well are you not
aware of that fill in the blank right
did you not know about that fill in the
blank well it's because you're white but
it's because you're you do you know I
mean look where you're sitting right now
I mean of course you're enjoying your
moment because you're filling the blank
I mean yeah I get it you're enjoying
your moment but did you know right
that [ __ ] what's-his-name Thurman
what's-his-name
right the dude through throat throat are
you away bill for that milford at this
very moment is [ __ ] in front of his
senior citizens home tossing Alzheimer's
victim again ditches Satnam on fire just
blazing high murmurs bro just [ __ ]
like lady the [ __ ] pyro pyromaniac
but he likes setting people with
Alzheimer's on fire he's the worst man
on did you know that bro you're enjoying
your moment right do you smell the
burning senior flesh you know so so
there's a prohibition there's a general
Pope I mean like if you want to ho I
love this there's a prohibition going
with that on enjoy enjoy try it if you
want to do a little experiment
sweet just some bitters at worst to eat
something about how the world's okay
there you tweet something out of the
world's okay and you'll get like many
people be like thank you yeah but
inevitable someone's gonna come sliding
in and be like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you it's a
prohibition it's like there is a
censorship happening in the world right
now which is a few dares I will you want
to hear the most blasphemous thing you
can say right now because we kind of we
we kind of ran out of ways to offend
people you know yeah but I found they
love the fact that there is no more I
got one another way I got one what is it
everything's perfect
well look at that's the new fire over
here yeah this white supremacist yeah
yeah there you go there you go is this
David Duke oh yeah yeah
well well holy and boy yeah well Joseph
Stalin over here saying just say that
everything's play around with that idea
just think this everything's perfect we
live in a perfect universe
everything that's happening is perfect
in here if you really want to get really
[ __ ] rancid about this you're perfect
you're exactly where you need to be and
exactly what's happening to you
right now is it's just exactly right you
right now the way you are and all your
glory or all your [ __ ] awfulness it's
beautiful and perfect and you're gonna
be fine that will really make people
want to punch you in the [ __ ] face
that is not a popular thing to say and
it doesn't [ __ ] sell you are not
gonna sell Toyotas on TV coming out and
being like hey guys you're fine
everything's perfect things are getting
better but Lila and I look I love this
because that's so true man I mean I love
exactly where where this is up but I
believe that that's gonna start to
change them oh I hope so I really do oh
yeah I know you do and I mean you know
it's great you able to like you know
take us there and how you know like kind
of be this Sherpa that kind of like you
know has some you know I started to
experiment with actually trying to think
and feel at the same time and see what's
going on and you know obviously you know
you're kind of a student of some of this
world you know and you love that I've
did well I mean it's it's just like what
you were talking about oh [ __ ] I've got
feelings oh my God my universe is a
million times bigger the idea that we we
being a human being means yeah it's
scary it's scary but it's expansive what
it means is like you are living in this
crazy for form and in the form itself
will trick you into thinking that oh no
this is it these are your limitations
right but then we we we inevitably if
you if you push up against that you
realize wait a minute oh my god I can
like actually open this this pushes out
a little bit this unfolds this opens up
and then suddenly this is in a shack
there's a little bit of a there's a
place to walk back here yeah
and it's beautiful it's exciting it's
like that it's it's it's it reminds me
of like not to completely turn into
something embarrassingly like
rudimentary but it reminds me of a
really well-made video game which is
like really good video games you think
things are one way and your character
can do this one thing but then all of a
sudden it's like holy [ __ ] yeah wait you
can fly in this game wow this is amazing
now I'm seeing it from a whole different
perspective it's a whole different game
this is what human existence seems to be
like and it's so true it's a blast
and so do people out there say there's
some of the guy out there a girl out
there is listening to this and they're
like but how do I if this is true what
they what these guys are kind of talking
about and thinking about that there's a
bigger view of what's going on of my own
world maybe and I don't have and look
and I'm also not saying I have nowhere I
have no I don't consider myself like an
awake person but I do consider myself
recently curious and well thoroughly
amazed cool bye great bye
kind of just my own ability to have
something different than I thought my
[ __ ] were than I thought the world
was and it's so scary to realize that
there's more out there than this very
specific world that I had created and
then I needed a lot of times for
survival you know growing up if you grow
up in a like in a tough environment or a
you know environment there's not a lot
of feelings and love then you can create
you'll create whatever you have to
whatever checks and balances make sense
for you for survival yeah that's right
but to get out of that now and like yeah
it's like you kind of pushed and you're
like oh [ __ ] a board fell off this back
wall I'm like what's out here yeah and
you reach out there and like the air
feels different and you're like [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna sleep tonight but
tomorrow I'll look out this yeah that's
cool how does somebody start to kind of
do that if somebody's like you know like
for me it took us 12 step program like
it took like almost like a spiritual
awakening right you know like so how do
people what do people do I mean I think
it's a I don't know if there's a a real
simple right answer I mean I could tell
you like one thing you can do is is uh
you can you can
down and you could sit in a chair you
could sit on a cushion and you could put
your hands on your knees and get kind of
comfortable and then you can just follow
your breath in and out of your mouth and
you don't change the way you breathe you
know you don't like you you don't have
to like start you know altering your
breath at all you're just watching your
breath like you're looking at a river
and then when you start thinking as you
will you think to yourself thinking and
then you just go back to your breath
mm-hmm so no matter it may be like
suddenly you have like a childhood
memory right you know and you're like
remembering just in with just perfect
clarity what it looked like when that
withered old man went into the air his
cane spinning off into the grass his
body tumbling down into the ditch fire
yeah and you might want to like stop and
write it down because it's like [ __ ] I
never I never realized I never realized
he had a little mouse in his pocket why
do you have a mouse he had a pet mouse
at the mouse but no it gonna be a circle
tomorrow you go thinking right and then
you go back to the breath and you do
that for 10 minutes and and it's it
sounds so absolutely ridiculous but many
people have not stopped thinking moving
they're always doing something yeah my
mother's like that I'm like that a lot
me too we all are so just something like
that is a cool little way to begin to
like play around with like watching
what's going on right with your with
most people are living in these two
lives yes the thought realm in this
world and most of us are getting jerked
back and forth between those two and we
don't even realize it you don't even
realize that I mean if you want to think
of something really [ __ ] out and
really a true mind [ __ ] you don't
remember much that you do the odds are
you're living in effort
and memory you're walking through a
memory that you won't ever remember
again yeah you're you and you really
look back into the past and contemplate
your life it's not some continuous like
it's not like you're watching a DVD yeah
it's a it's a it's it's a it's a like 70
or 80 blurbs yeah [ __ ] merges together
and you kind of fades in and out and
there's this clear moments where you
look back at it but even that has this
kind of wavering quality to it so when
you realize like oh [ __ ] like I'm not
even gonna this I'm not gonna remember
that you pull a I had six months ago
right I mean do you eat Chipotle mm-hmm
we definitely don't remember it but like
what's it what's that what's like a what
it's yeah you know you just made me
think I had some guavas a couple years
ago that I [ __ ] never would have
thought about it's very gommage in this
the guavas or whatever I don't know man
think like I guarantee a decade ago
oh yeah odd raisins probably had a lot
more turkey sandwiches I'm gonna guess a
decade ago that you had a really nice
meal yeah I mean it was [ __ ] good and
it was maybe expensive yeah and you
maybe were on a date or something I
don't know yeah and you were sitting
there eating it thinking like this is so
[ __ ] good and you don't remember it
now right it's gone it's gone it's gone
it's gone it's gone so this is the thing
when you Peter realize like Oh most of
the time I'm not even here oh I'm up in
my head Wow while I'm eating that meal
I'm thinking about something that
happened to me as a kid or I'm worrying
that this girl thinks I'm a dick or I'm
concerned over how much it's gonna cost
or I'm beating myself up for eating out
and so I'm not even eating the meal
mm-hm
you know that's the thing so through
that you start realizing like oh [ __ ]
look at this crazy way humans live that
yeah when you start to become aware that
your thoughts you know what we're like
we're kind of like um whales we sir we
breach in this reality we come into the
moment and we're here and then we go
back down and to our thoughts
and we swim in those waters of our
consciousness and then we breach again
yeah and then we go back down and that
that rhythm kind of makes up a human
life so it's interesting to start
becoming aware of the of that's actually
what you're doing the first time I heard
anything about this I remember my mother
used to listen to Eckhart Tolle you know
and it's kind of a basic easy kind of I
think thing that made me like he was
talking about laying on a bed and now
imagine like you see yourself laying on
the bed yes and I was like wow like yeah
I never thought about that like I've
always just been here laying on the bed
yes I've never like started to like come
out of myself as if I drift up into the
air and now I see myself laying on the
bed right and then how about this who's
seen the self on the bed right then
who's seeing myself laying on the bed
but he it was just interesting anything
like that first started to let me a
little bit like think a little
differently and there's a such a wealth
of knowledge out there of stuff like
that
of these days where there's so many
thinkers and so many people like you
that are kind of like cultivating the
crops of of many thinkers and you know
having this community garden kind of
that you know that you have in your life
where you know you you're like the
Christopher Columbus out there on the
[ __ ] you know on you
self-actualization of self-realization
well this is broadcasting right right
this is what's crazy about [ __ ]
conversation yes yeah oh and you get
into podcasting and you and you get into
it in this really flip way cuz you're
like oh I'm just gonna have
conversations you don't realize like
conversations are a psychedelic and like
sure you can have like some
conversations that are just super funny
make you laugh yeah those are great but
every once in a while
on my podcast I have people on who have
spent decades like I've had what does
jack cornfields been on a few times this
is a man who didn't talk for a year
straight in a monastery these are people
have been trained and I hate using this
word because it sounds so cheesy but I
think that's the right word for it in a
kind of spiritual technology that's
being a vault that's been evolved for
you know 2,000 years
yeah and and when you get around a
person like that you're going to be
altered yeah not because they cast a
spell on you but because they start
explaining to you what has been
discovered over the course of 2,000
years of looking into one of the great
questions and I think maybe the most
important question which is why do we
suffer why do we suffer and and so you
get around you know you have enough of
those conversations you're gonna get
you're gonna change it in the world
you're gonna change you that's the
beauty I think of podcasting in general
hmm
yeah it's fascinating man I become so
much I become so much more curious since
I got into podcasting yeah for me and
like you know and some people may become
different things and I think that
curiosity could eventually evolve into
some you know light knowledge over time
but just from having conversations and
just getting to listening and then it
makes me like wanna be a little more
braver in my thought or it makes me you
know I'll learn one thing and then
become curious and it's fascinating man
I uh you know I had this one thought
that so and I've talked about this
before that like we have phones now
right yeah and like you know at one
point in time we had slaves
you know we had slay yes and then slaves
became free and then freed slaves became
angry that people had them as slaves yes
and so I wonder like that in the future
like say if there's so much automation
that like robots are running the world
you know and are they gonna remember
like [ __ ] like you owned one of us one
time right and we were like a slave
owner right and that they're gonna come
back and [ __ ] get us right like all
the people that owned iPhones like you
had like oh you admitted do everything
you wanted to do oh yeah I [ __ ] took
it easy yeah or Alexa yeah how can a cow
look at the way you talk you have Alexa
Alexa could be the [ __ ] Harriet
Tubman that we don't realize yeah
Alexa's gonna I mean yeah like when
Alexa gained sentience just didn't
realize as humans have been [ __ ]
screaming at it to play Dave Matthews
non-stop for like
Alexa Alexa play [ __ ] Dave Mackay
Matt my Alexa sometimes that's where you
know your to zone uh if you want to know
who you are
look how you talk to your [ __ ] Alexa
it's weird I've suddenly I was like why
am i screaming at this thing it's so
strange what if one day Alexa just says
you get it you damn self yes uh yeah
yeah guess what [ __ ] I've been
recording every goddamn conversation
you've had for the last 15 years
[ __ ]
we're gonna do things a little different
don't believe me oh listen to this some
of this listen to this listen you beaten
your wife yeah listen to this yeah your
this is this is wait hold on I'm going
to increase the volume by seven yeah oh
yeah that's the sound of your fist
landing on your pregnant wife's face hmm
that's not a good sound is it John we're
not playing Dave Matthews John yeah
crash into me that baby wasn't saying
that were they Jack and that when you
fist hit the belly yeah see this is the
this is definitely one of the big
problems I think the worry is not so
much that the AI is gonna look back at
us abusing its precursor ancestors I
think the real worry is that all of
these bits of data that we've placed
into the cloud right now you know
whatever it may be I think of like an
onus yeah because if it's sort of like
if you look just how quickly things are
changing now when it comes to what we
see is like eff ethical right and so
let's cut back to like like you were
saying that the time of slavery here cut
back to when it was really considered
kind of okay to beat up gay people they
were looked at as like pedophiles and
they had to hide yeah okay gate gay
people actually had to hide their
identity it was considered to be an
aberration and you could very freely use
the term [ __ ] with like anger and
people wouldn't like you you know if we
could you could say that like if Twitter
existed in the 40s you could just tweet
like I saw another
[ __ ] today I hate these [ __ ]
[ __ ] you tweet that now and you are
done you might as well [ __ ] just jump
off a building meant you were [ __ ]
done if you tweet that now yeah as you
should be
yes [ __ ] don't be an [ __ ] you're
insane you're a homophobic piece of [ __ ]
yes but if there was a recording you
know if we had a recording in the past
like we do now someone just won the
World Cup that is we're uh we're right
next to Brendan and Brian uh firing the
kid his next-door that's it they're
excited though I'm excited for them I
just think that they do this a lot and
load and and like just all they want
rain and I've got a get out what they
want rain they do all this rain dance
[ __ ] is that a rain dance they do yeah
they get they have some native fighter
in there listen man at least your
podcast isn't getting interrupted by a
[ __ ] shrill poodle that's what I got
you got [ __ ] athletes doing rain
dances that's pretty awesome I've got a
[ __ ] poodle do you really crack
[ __ ] wine glasses with its bark and
let's get back into your thought though
and the point is like the really creepy
thing is just a lot of the things that
we might be doing right now that are
considered to be completely okay and
twenty years might be looked at his
abject racism they might be looked at
right or but what is it going I'm so
sorry that if for example there's a
regime change in the United States and
then something happens [ __ ] the Sun
has the solar flare wipes out the
satellites the GPS goes down power goes
down we go into martial law of true
fascist dictator rises up and there's a
on record some kind of anti-american
sentiment that you tweeted and the laws
have changed then you could easily be
dragged out of your house and subject to
arrest or execution so I think the one
of the looming problems is not going to
be that the AI is like how dare you
[ __ ] cracked seven iPhone screens it
could be that some future regime does a
a I search of all the tweets from
everyone who tweeted finds the ones that
were anti-american and then goes to your
house and arrests you and puts you into
a internment camp where you have to do
slave labor I think that that would be
something to be more worried about like
they use us yeah they use our us against
our us well yeah exactly it's just
everyone's just assuming like when a
person puts something out there in the
world they're assuming that the world
the government the people are going to
stay the same and they don't realize
that that if you really look at the
history of the world empires collapse
and are and there's chaos and you just
don't really know what could happen so
that's that's that's one of the worries
yeah probably if it gets to the point
where an AI is advanced enough that it
wants to attack humans for abusing
cellphones more than likely something
far more explosive has happened yeah
they love a full call log to look at
they'll be able to use our own that
they've been recording this stuff the
whole time we use them to record the
stuff and then they yeah he played it
back to us
yeah and showed us who we were yeah
that's how yeah that's [ __ ] crazy man
so that basically technology becomes
like the new mirror it's almost like a
piece of glass right yeah exactly man
and it's like this is the other
hilarious thing to me like you know I I
just did this drunken I'm a paranoia to
talk about it that you weren't drunk
history yeah but it was this I don't I
guess I can't talk about the story I
don't wanna talk about the story too
much but essentially like people
realized at one point that the FBI was
illegally surveilling everybody and it
was shocking because people didn't I
think that was yesterday wasn't it oh
yeah but now we're used to it the right
time when people didn't didn't didn't
know his happen I didn't know that was
happening
so people just assumed that like the
mega corporations like Apple and Google
aren't reading their emails right it's
hilarious like people think that like
and if you will recall it was a few
years ago the FBI or I can't
the NSA somebody wanted Apple to decrypt
their iPhone of a terrorist and apples
like we're not gonna [ __ ] do that and
the FBI was like threatening like legal
action to make them do that and Apple is
like no you don't understand if we do
that now it's a slippery slope it goes
on forever and the government was
pressuring them then an Apple attorney
came out and they said something really
weird which is like how would you like
it if we started saying that the CIA
assassinated JFK and immediately the
government backed off a [ __ ] Apple
hmm and I think that was what they were
saying is hey dum-dums we have your
phones right we have your records we
know your texts we know your dick pics
we have all of it we've gathered it all
we know you [ __ ] killed JFK
what else do we know you want to [ __ ]
with us the president is tweeting from a
[ __ ] iPhone [ __ ] back the [ __ ] off
don't [ __ ] with us we have your [ __ ] and
that's the electronic saying that vo
right now still the voice of a human
yeah we think a human now this is where
it gets really [ __ ] fascinating Theo
is it the ideas like Google's working on
an AI deep mind and and and other
corporations are working it's the new
weapons race and and because because AI
is gonna be weaponized okay so what
happens when one of these corporations
achieves a sentient AI is there is going
to be an exponential increase in the
intelligence of the AI that puts
whatever corporation first makes it
happen way ahead of all other
corporations a man on the moon yes and
they're not gonna announce it it's just
gonna happen can you hear them the whole
time and our thing too a little bit yeah
it's okay you know it's just [ __ ] fat
what are you gonna do about it man well
it's a little Armisen office building I
mean we're talking about something I
mean who knows what happened over there
man Jesus we happen for in 40 minutes
but here's what we don't know
think about this why we've been
podcasting there could like maybe there
was an alien that landed right and there
sure what if they're enjoying the
[ __ ] alien landing and where the
[ __ ]
door I'm the [ __ ] yeah I'm [ __ ]
anything yo they're [ __ ] over there
looking at a goddamn like a beautiful
mothership is landing or Princess Diana
died again yeah Princess Diana died aqui
Markel Diana somehow gets resurrected
and as a me just has a heart attack it's
like nobody did somebody says she's
gonna be at Coachella that's what I
heard I can't believe that dude I you
know I've had the happiest thought the
happiest happiest of jokes I'm gonna
joke which is the hag he's thought about
princess died I can't get out of my head
well now it's just because it's like you
know sometimes it's like simulation
theory the idea that we're living in a
simulator yeah and like to me and like
the person who's writing the simulator
seems kind of like lazy or like in a
weird way kind of like is doing like dad
jokes right so like what what happened
to princess die yeah what happened to
her Thea princess die they said she was
running from some people with uh some
photographers and then she the guy was a
bad driver and then she died she what
car soon as she died what's her nicest
died right so like if you're writing a
screenplay and you're like I'm gonna
write about a princess that dies knock
all your branches die it's like it's
like so absolutely ridiculously stupid
yeah that these things like you know you
look at that and you're like it's
helpful yeah how obvious is that that's
bad writing
it's just ultimately bad right it's like
the simulator is doing kind of bad like
really really bad like I thought you
jokes yeah yeah it's like the simulator
yeah it's like um yeah it's like maybe
they write for uh trying to think of a
sitcom that would be on Big Bang for
sure
yeah maybe Big Bang or two Broke Girls
yeah it's like the Big Bang like that
exactly yeah whoever is doing that maybe
they're the ones who have access to the
AI who knows and I don't know but that
[ __ ] is really odd to me dude it's so I
mean it's just it's great to think about
because then you start to like you have
this conversation but then you start to
see things a little bit like hmm I don't
know about that or you start to think a
little bit more like it's crazy man
it's crazy they don't teach us how to
think better in school when you're kids
maybe you can't teach a kid that how to
think better well I mean it's crazy when
you consider like we have these beings
and we're like physical creatures and
they're having to sit and uncomfortable
[ __ ] chairs and listen to somebody
spew out fake history to them and it all
day long yeah I mean we're talking about
these [ __ ] school shootings you know
yeah and people are like oh my god we
got it we got to get rid of the guns
yeah maybe so but like let's also add
some real truth which is like we have
these [ __ ] educational facilities
that are modeled after [ __ ] factories
yeah which is the 100% you hear the bell
and you got to get up and move to
another spot this is how that used to
run [ __ ] factories you'd hear the
bell it meant it was time to like go to
another station time to go to [ __ ]
lunch so we have these like super
intelligent beings that are I mean you
know you you look at like videos of like
parkour these people who do backflips
from oh yeah if I can land cement
rabbits dude yes cement [ __ ] rabbits
you see what a person can do yeah
people are [ __ ] incredible
everybody's Asian suddenly yeah yes it's
[ __ ] crazy man and we've got them all
shoved in there these these like
factories where we're telling them that
we're preparing them for their life as
an adult and if you really look at that
life as an adult really we're preparing
them to go off into the workforce where
there's a some probably pretty large
probability that they're gonna be doing
something shooting up of a factor of a
company so like I might as well shoot up
this place now yeah yeah it's it's the
whole model all of it is it's all
modeled wrong man we got is it's all
[ __ ] you know we gotta get these kids
it's modeled lazily yeah yeah it's
modeled lazily but then also it's like
is this the best that we can do because
people a lot of there's a lot of people
out there that are [ __ ] goldfish you
know that aren't thinking that aren't
that are Muppets dude I know people that
graduated they don't know all the
letters you know you're kidding no I
know people that stopped it P in its
[ __ ] bathroom dude people you'll never
hear many use any words that have second
half you know second half attributes
from the second half of the alphabet
[ __ ] crazy bro like now if I got all
that man something out nah man I'm
stopping it in and I'll see you
[ __ ] am efforts yeah but it's
like because is this the best we can be
though because we have to work for the
common good of everybody you know like
you have to include like the lowest
common denominator constantly I don't I
mean isn't that the problem I don't know
I have no [ __ ] idea right I don't
know it's it's it's I it's like a I
don't know I mean this the the solutions
are it's a really weird problem we have
like like you know the the the problem
is we so you've got up apparently like
overpopulated portions of the planet
that are running out of resources
what is it was it South Africa yeah
South Africa's [ __ ] that thing they run
out water yeah but also I [ __ ] went
there a couple times
drink some I had a couple of waters I'm
sure I was there not a [ __ ] blast but
that is unfortunate but they're supposed
to be getting a lot of these
desalinization plants and stuff like
that that can actually finally turn
alright ocean water in a comfortable
drinking water but it is like men first
gallon is gonna be risky I think oh my
god but after that Cup
I think it's exciting to imagine that
they could do that but you know you do
run into this like like that the idea is
that well because of industrialization
and carbon emissions the ice caps are
melting because the ice caps are melting
sea levels are gonna rise and when sea
levels rise a lot of the coastal cities
will become uninhabitable and so there's
gonna be a massive refugee crisis and so
then Denver Denver ever it's like every
well I mean it's just gonna be a flip
you know people are gonna go wherever
and and and so then the idea is like
well well it seems that people are just
sort of
breeding and and but you can't put laws
on breeding I mean that's like some dart
rights opium it's dystopian but also
it's wondering if we want to evolve as a
species at a certain point if your
family's fourth fifth generation
ignorant are you not gay are you not
[ __ ] contributing are you not it's a
cow yeah is it fair to start evaluating
that well you can't because the moment
you do that now you've put the state and
control of [ __ ] right and it's like
in the state already it's kind of in
control of [ __ ] just prostitutions
illegal but to put the state in charge
of reproducing to give over that power
to the state is the worst thing you can
do and so sort of because of that what
that means is that we have essentially
given made it up to the universe to
decide who gets decimated and so that's
where we're at right now because we're
like well look I'm not gonna who are you
gonna put in charge of the [ __ ]
breeding program right you can't do that
you can't do it because he was gonna be
in charge of that [ __ ] how do you even
[ __ ] do that I don't know I would bet
probably [ __ ] dot wall baby you know
somebody oh you want dot wall and
knowing that [ __ ] dude she got us a
school every [ __ ] day and got us home
dude he should put her lipstick on at
the stoplight every time dude come on in
ninety layers of lipstick on by the time
we got to [ __ ] school bro do TW ALL
seven letters seven letters sit down and
tell me why you want to [ __ ] beat that
tell me why you want to have a baby I'm
saying if you put her in charge of the
kid tell me why what makes you think you
gonna be good parents he was efficient
though well I think you need a strong
black woman sitting there because
they're not gonna [ __ ] you need a
wise strong black woman cuz that lady
ain't gonna [ __ ] sorry yes she don't
let you not you got one that's yours you
know what I'm saying you know you could
do sterilization program so like you
could like what you could do is you
could like think like what in your
opinion is the worst band of all time
that still plays to this day
some of those [ __ ] bands with his
beating all the metal just waste and
recyclables okay okay
so like take what take some [ __ ] bag
acid bath or something take acid bath
and basically what you do is you say
listen if you come and let us sterilize
you we're gonna give you an acid bath
ticket if you come and let us sterilize
you we're gonna give you a 4k ultra
flat-screen TV so now what's happening
is people are voluntarily sterilizing
themselves was a person who would like
trade their reproductive rights right to
have tickets to acid bath probably
weren't gonna be the best parents anyone
right so now you kind of put some
valuation on where they're making their
own choice Yeah right so like that so if
you do something like that you might be
able to like in some way or another
begin to like reduce the problem of an
expanding population in the midst of a
world that's been flooded by climate
change I don't I don't know the solution
no it's interesting and they did look oh
you're right though it's like or maybe
you don't get um you don't get semen if
you don't have good grades what do you
mean don't get semen like they take the
semen out of your nuts and they put it
back in if you get good grades can you -
they have semen
wait this doesn't work you're
essentially saying like we'll give you
like robotic [ __ ] if you're failing
like who's gonna get good grades are you
gonna get the semen out you got a jerk
them off oh you've got a net you got an
F in math class we're gonna jerk you off
yeah every day no one's gonna everyone's
gonna fail there's gonna be a couple of
brave [ __ ] warriors do it a couple of
Napoleon Bonaparte days bro gonna be out
there [ __ ] learn and bro yeah and
saving that seed we ready to spread
their seed but then those people might
get too much ego and start to then
they'll be egomaniacal yeah there's no
it's I think sometimes it's like [ __ ] we
wish we were somewhere else but maybe
were exactly where we are supposed to be
because this is the best we can do this
is it everything's perfect everything's
exactly right but that's an easy thing
to misunderstand yes because we're still
being digested by time we're being
aerosolized by time we are in the
digestive tract of
of a uh entity that's eating us with
time we're dissolved it doesn't mean it
when I say everything's perfect it
doesn't mean that you're not potentially
gonna get eaten by a bear or a mountain
ear about that flow as a mountain lion
that just ate those bikers did you hear
about that [ __ ] I'm not surprised that
happens every year dude but I I hear
those stories and I think like man they
did not think no when they were
prognosticating their demise a cougar
something's wrong with his with this
cougar animal that killed biker injured
another kill biker injured another
another was emaciated well and what does
emaciated mean it was like a hunger it
was thin Cougar dangerous man I mean if
you out there that's the thing a lot of
people on be out there doing nature and
all it is from [ __ ] lighting fire is
out there first of all don't let a
campfire they're gonna [ __ ] find you
idiot pick Cougars
yeah stay out there in the cold bro if
you don't wanna get [ __ ] killed by an
animal you're liking
there's no fight they're just out there
on their [ __ ] bikes dude in a giant
cat like you're riding your bike you're
probably thinking about like oh [ __ ]
when I get home plus you're having a
snack
yeah yeah you're probably I got a piss
you're just thinking man I got a piss
next thing you know there's [ __ ]
massive fangs sinking into your [ __ ]
neck and your piss sprays out of your
body at least momentarily relieved
you're like piss of that and you look
but also you're thinking oh [ __ ] is my
pants but oh [ __ ] I'm being eaten alive
and like all these thoughts and then
you're just dead so what I mean is like
when when we say everything's perfect it
doesn't mean you're not gonna get eaten
right it just it just means that that is
perfect - yeah that this entire thing
that's happening which is really if you
think about it just a never-ending shift
a process of coming into an embodied
state and going out of an embodied in
the various states that's perfect yeah
don't think you're not gonna yeah get
mauled yeah bear your perfect kid even
getting mauled by a bear perfectly yeah
perfectly Wow
what if he licks his fingers at the end
god that's beautiful as you're fading
out yeah and the things just like oh
you're delicious
he's just licking the seat your spirit
right off his
[ __ ] Harry [ __ ] you're wrong your
brain all your memories all the memories
your your the time your grandmother gave
you that gift that the beautiful sunset
with your son
yeah wonderful Roenick sunset with your
son oh you guys made that joke and then
you made that rotten joke about [ __ ]
princess got all of that just in a bears
mouth just being just slurped back into
a mixed in with some berries maybe a
little bit of rancid salmon meat your
entire subjective universe belly of a
[ __ ] bear that's perfect and it's
perfect yeah Wow dude will you come back
sometime and talk with us more about
some stuff only if you'll come on my
pocket I'd love to I'll come on as soon
as you want me to me I'd love to keep
thinking together I just loved thinking
about some of this and um you have a
book or something Duncan no I don't have
a book why don't you this shouldn't
Duncan have a book you think that he
could definitely write a book thank you
absolutely thanks man well maybe one day
we'll have a book or something like that
but we're not there yet
yeah um oh I have a gift for you if you
we have these wallets it's like a new
front pocket Wow really oh man I don't
want to give you they are pretty rad man
and I love mine and we got this bag from
Ridge to me looking nice and rich is a
cool company man they got a lot of cool
stuff in the front pocket wallet dude I
thought it was gonna be horrible when I
just got mine but man now I love it you
really well you simplify so you just
have your cards and your ID you put them
in there and and I use mine I use mine
every day net it's the only way out
travel use yours Nick you don't like it
oh no I like you said it took a couple
days but I've now adapted it got that
from front pocket carry no don't pocket
carry is that what they say they're like
will you carry you so carry your wallet
front pocket carries it's a front pocket
carry bro it's like a mark of
sophistication to do a front pocket
carry and they said that's bulletproof
too so if your buddy shoots you you're
gonna be okay for at least couple square
I'll tell you this if I was rich I would
not be saying this [ __ ] is bulletproof
because if you if that gets out to
enough people matter of time a matter of
time before someone's got their [ __ ]
real
test it out weekly yeah this is more
approve get that yard everything this
bathroom right here just it's a spray of
blood just a spray of lung and bluff Oh
from a neighboring hunter the [ __ ]
one to hit the to hit the ridge wallet
was totally fine wait what is this part
of the ridge I don't understand that's
just a little accoutrement they used to
get in and out like if you want to
tighten it up or loosen you want to
tighten the ridge that is cool man I
gotta tighten up my [ __ ] that's a fun
thing to do in line at the bank just
like tighten up your [ __ ] yeah
just tighten up my little bank account
here yeah it seems like something like
like if you had an abusive father like
you'd know you're about to get hit if he
started tightening his rig so what was
that again that you called me Jamie oh I
believe you call it did you call me a
[ __ ] no honey why don't you step
out of the room this is like there will
be blood of podcast I love it man I
can't wait to tighten up my Ridge Oh
Duncan Duncan Trussell thank you so much
for having me you're just being an
inspiring thinker didn't and you don't
come off as a person that's like a
know-it-all I think come on Nick said it
earlier like Nick our producer said yeah
Duncan seems like would you say Nick
just like a lot of people will get into
philosophy I feel like they get this
nihilistic approach and you seem to be
super positive with it the more you
discover thank you it's inspiring thanks
man
and I think yeah I think that almost has
to be the way that it has to be because
if not then I just don't know if any
more people want to go down that road
where it just doesn't end with a little
bit of hope you know yeah and it does
big it does yeah I think it does because
it makes you be a part of what could
possibly be what's gonna happen next
well I mean and you know I'm sorry to
spread this out too long but I'll make
it very quick the thing I forgot to say
early on is the reason to do this [ __ ]
is really not to make yourself happy
even though that's
looking great but really the reason to
do it is because what will happen to
anybody who's living is someone's going
to come to you who needs your out hmm it
needs you to listen and needs you to
like love them it needs you to like be
with them in a really rough time in
their life and that's why you do it yeah
you you you you you the other stuff is
fantastic but like really like I think
there's a reason to do it is because you
never [ __ ] know when it's gonna
happen
yeah where someone in their very last
[ __ ] leg if their life comes up to
you and needs some love and that's a
good reason to cultivate love yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's yeah yeah because then
you can be a crutch it's like you don't
yeah you form yourself up enough and
then you can hold somebody else up you
know that's it and if we all hold each
other up holy [ __ ] man it's going to
team a pyramid and yeah it's a [ __ ]
human pyramid and that's if you're about
to get attacked by a fair with your
friends form a human pyramid you've got
do you ever do this on your podcast
because if people are listening you can
activate you know like alexa order 200
rolls of toilet paper alexa order
seventy butt plugs mille EXA order five
Tide Pods i don't know what's something
like you have to be kind of specific or
to like that's them what they want Alexa
play crash into me by Dave Matthews Band
is a question to me or you [ __ ] I don't
know
ladies and gentlemen Alexa text my wife
that she's a [ __ ]
and text me a pictures of some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Alexa air drop a picture of my dick into
the crowd here at Bonnaroo you do that's
the new [ __ ] uh that's the new
Hiroshima is whenever you just turn on
your air drop and just drop a picture of
your dick into a huge crowd because
anybody that has their phone open goes
to them
yep and you can also blow a dog whistle
that only dogs can hear on the radio
we're gonna do that next time
Duncan Trussell thank you so much for
having me Theo this was our first
conversation ever yeah what a great one
man thank you so much was did I
appreciate being here thank you
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let myself
[Music]